the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
well ok so first important things about
the course plans for the course and then
I'm today I'm going to move to the new
next section of the notes section 2 or
part 2 I should say and actually I'll
skip for the moment section 2 1 and go
to section 2 2 and all the SEC's all of
chapter 2 will come to you probably
today or latest tomorrow so that's where
we're going next we're following the
notes pretty carefully except I'm going
to skip the section on tensors until I
learn more
basically yeah yeah I could say a little
about tensors but this flows this flows
naturally using the SVD so it's just
terribly important problem least squares
and of course I know that you've seen
one or two ways to do least squares and
it's really the whole subject comes
together here I want to say something
before I send out a plan for looking
ahead for the course as a whole so
there's no final exam and I don't really
see how to examine you how to give tests
I could of course create our tests use
it on about the linear algebra part but
I don't think it's it's not sort of the
style of this course to
to expect you quickly to create a proof
or something in in our class but I think
so I think and especially looking at
what we're headed for and moving quite
steadily in that direction is all these
all the problems that these this linear
algebra is is aimed at right up to an
including conjugate gradient descent and
and deep learning the the big the
overwhelmingly important and lively
active research area that's I couldn't
do better than to get keep the course
going in that direction so I think what
I would ask you to do is late late and
sort of april/may the regular homeworks
I'll discontinue at a certain point and
then instead I'll be asking and
encouraging a project I don't know if
that's the right word to be using in
which you use what we've done for and
I'll send out a message on stellar
listing like five or six areas and only
I mean one of them is the machine
learning deep learning part but they're
all the other parts that that that
things we've learned to are learning how
to do how to find sparse solutions for
example or or something about the
pseudo-inverse all kinds of things so
that's my goal is to would give you
something to do which uses the material
you've learned and look I I'm not
expecting a thesis but it's a it's a
good chance so it will be more than just
like drag in some code for deep learning
and and some data matrix and do it
but we'll chalk amaura that's a time
comes
so like I just thought I'd say before
sending out the announcement I would say
it's coming about what as a as a larger
scale than single one week homeworks
would be here before and he saw it's
about that I haven't given it I haven't
given you details so let me do that with
a message and then ask again but I'm
open to I hope you've understood I think
you have that that if you make
suggestions either directly to my email
or on Piazza or whatever they get paid
attention to okay Michelle you just go
forward with least squares so what's the
least squares problem and what are these
four ways each each bringing so let me
speak about the pseudo-inverse first
okay the pseudo inverse of a matrix
alright good so we have a matrix a M by
N and the pseudo-inverse I'm going to
call a plus and it naturally it's gonna
be n by M I'm going to multiply those
together and I'm gonna get as near to
the identity as I can that's the idea of
course of the pseudo-inverse the word
pseudo is in there so so no one's
deceived it's not an actual inverse oh
if the matrix is square and has an
inverse of course then if if a inverse
exists which which requires a everybody
remembers it requires the matrix to be
square because I mean inverse on both
sides and and it requires rank in full
rank then the inverse will exist you can
check it MATLAB would check it by
computing the pivots in elimination
finding and pivots so if a inverse
exists which means a and a times a
inverse and a inverse times a both give
I then a plus is a inverse of course the
pseudo inverse is the inverse when there
is one but I'm thinking about cases
where either the matrix is rectangular
or or it has zero eigenvalues it it's it
could be square but has a null space
other than just the zero vector in other
words the columns are dependent what can
we do then about inverting it we can't
literally invert it if if a has a null
space then when I multiply by a vector X
in that null space ax will be zero and
when I multiply by a inverse still zero
that can't change the zero so if there
is an X in the null space then this
can't happen but so we just do the best
we can and that's what the pseudo
inverse is and so let me draw a picture
of the the picture you know of the row
space and the null space okay and it's
there you see there is a null space and
over here I have the column space and
the null space of a transpose okay so
this is the row space of course that's a
column space of a and of a transpose and
there's the column space of a okay so
which part of that picture is invertible
and which part of the picture is
hopeless the top part is invertible this
is the are sort of our dimensional row
space our dimensional column space a
takes a vector in here zaps it into
every oh you always end up in the column
space here here here I take a vector in
the
row space say X and it gets mapped to ax
and between those two spaces a is
entirely invertible you know you you get
separate vectors here go to separate
vectors in the column space and the
inverse just brings it back so we know
what the pseudo-inverse should do
it'll take a we'll take go that way and
a plus the pseudo-inverse will be just
it will give us on the top half of the
picture it'll give us a plus we'll take
ax back to x4 in the in the top half now
what about here that's where we have
trouble we don't have that's what spoils
our inverse if there's a null space
vector then it goes where when you
multiply by a this guy in the null space
goes to zero usually along a straighter
line than I've drawn but go there gets
to zero so you you can't raise it from
the dead so to speak you can't recover
it one of you there's no way inverse so
we have to think what shall a inverse do
to this space here where nobody's
hitting it so it's this was this would
be the null space of a transpose because
8/8 sorry yeah what should the
pseudo-inverse do I said what should the
inverse do the inverse is helpless but
we have to to define a plus I've said
what it should do on that guy on the
column space it should take everything
in the column space back where it came
from but what should it do on this
orthogonal space where yeah just tell me
what what what do you think if I have
some vector here that's it's called that
V R plus one that would
be like so here here I have a basis of a
nice a nice basis for the column space
this V's I would use V's for the for the
ones that come up in the SVD they're
orthogonal and they come from orthogonal
use so that top half is great what shall
I do with this stuff I'm gonna send that
back by a plus and where am I going what
am I gonna do with it send it to know
where else could it go zero is the right
answer all this stuff goes back to zero
I'm looking for a linear Mayton linear
operator a matrix and I have to think of
once I've decided what to do with all
those and what to do with all these then
I know what to do with any combination
so I've got it I've got it so so the
idea will be this is true for X in the
row space for X in the row space if X is
in the row space ax is in the column
space and a inverse just brings it back
as it should and and in a in the case of
an invertible matrix a what happens to
my picture what does this picture
looking like if a is actually a six by
six invertible matrix in that case
what's what's in my picture and what is
not in my picture all this null space
stuff isn't there a null space is just
the zero vector but all that I don't
have to worry about but in general I do
have to say so that the point is that a
plus on the what what am i calling this
ooh it's a null space of a transpose or
or whatever on on V R plus 1 to the N
those those though
those all those vectors the the guys
that are not in the orthogonal to the
column space then your your we have to
say what does a plus do to them and the
answer is it takes them all to zero so
there's a picture using the what I call
the big picture of linear algebra the
four spaces you see what a plus should
do now I need a little formula for it
I've got a I've got the plan for what it
should be and it's they're sort of a
natural thing so A plus a is you could
say up it's a projection matrix it's not
the identity matrix because because if X
is in the null space a plus ay ay ay
plus a will take it to zero but so so
it's a project a plus a is the identity
on the top half and zero on the bottom
half that's that's really what the
matrix is and now I want a simple
formula for it and I guess my message
here is that if we're looking for a nice
expression start with the SVD because
the SVD works for any matrix and it
writes it as an orthogonal matrix times
the diagonal matrix times an orthogonal
matrix and now I want to invert it well
suppose a had an inverse what would that
be if this is F invertible what would be
the SVD of a inverse what would be the
singular value decomposition if if this
is good so when is this going to be good
that what would that make what would I
have to know about that matrix Sigma
that diagonal matrix in the middle if
this is truly an invertible matrix well
know what's its name those are not
eigenvalues well there I can values of
a transpose a but their singular value
singular violets fine so that's the
singular value matrix and what would be
the situation if if a had an inverse
there would be no zeros all their
singular values would be sitting there
Sigma 1 2 Sigma N what would be the
shape of this Sigma matrix if if if I
have an inverse then I've it's got to be
square and by N so what's the shape of
the Sigma guy also square and by n so so
the invertible case would be and I'm
gonna erase this in a minute the
invertible case would be when Sigma is
just that that would be the invertible
case so let's see can you finish this
formula what would be the SVD of a
inverse so I've given the SVD of a I'm
given the U and this Sigma is cool and
the V transpose what's the inverse of
that
well yeah I'm just really asking you
what's the inverse of that product of
three matrices what comes first here V
the inverse of V transpose is V that's
because V is a orthogonal matrix the
inverse of Sigma I just 1 over it is
just the Sigma inverse it's obvious what
that means and the inverse of U would go
here and that is U transpose great ok so
this is f invertible if invertible we
know what the SVD of a inverse is it
just takes the V's back to the eu's
takes it or they use back to the V's
whichever ok ok now we've got to do it
if we're going to allow if we're gonna
get beyond this limit the situation
allow the matrix Sigma to be rectangular
then let me just show you how the idea
here
so so now I'm gonna say now Sigma in
general its rectangular it's got our non
zeros on the diagonal but then it quits
so it's it's got a bunch of zeros that
to make it not invertible but let's do
our best and pseudo-inverse okay so now
I'll help me get started on a formula
for using I want to write this a plus
which are described up there in terms of
the subspaces now I'm going to describe
a plus in terms of you Sigma and V the
in the SVD guys okay so what what shall
I start with here well let me give a
hint I'll just that was a great start my
V is still an orthogonal matrix V
transpose is still an orthogonal matrix
I'll invert it at the end
the U was no problem all the problems
are in Sigma and Sigma remember Sigma so
it's it's rectangular maybe I'll make it
like wide for to wide and maybe I'll
only give it to non zeros and then all
the rest so the rank of my matrix a is 2
but the m and n are bigger than 2 it's
it's just got two independent columns
and then then it's just sort of totally
singular okay so my question is what am
I going to put there and I've described
it one way but now I'm gonna describe it
another way well let me just say what I
what I'll put there is the pseudo
inverse of Sigma I can't put Sigma
inverse you using that symbol because it
there is no such thing with this I can't
invert it so that's the best I can do so
I'm almost done but to finish I have to
tell you what does that
what what is this thing so Sigma plus
I'm now going to tell you Sigma plus and
then that's what should sit there in the
middle so if Sigma is this diagonal
matrix which quits after two Sigma's
what should Sigma plus be well first of
all it should be rectangular the other
way if this was M by n column and
columns and M rows now I want to have n
rows and M columns and yeah here's the
question what's the best inverse you
could come up with for that Sigma I mean
if somebody independent of 1806 five if
somebody asks you do your best to invert
that matrix I think we'd all agree it is
yeah one over the Sigma one would come
there and one over Sigma two then non
zeros and then zeros I think you just
the way up there we didn't we didn't
know what to do
when there was nothing good to do zero
was there was the right answer so so
this is all zeroes of course it's
rectangular the other way but do you see
that if I multiply Sigma plus times
Sigma if I multiply the pseudo inverse
times the matrix what do I get if I
multiply that by that what does that
multiplication produce can you describe
the well or I can when you tell me what
it looks like I'll write it down so what
is Sigma plus time Sigma if Sigma is a
diagonal Sigma plus is a diagonal and
they both quit after two guys what do I
have one because Sigma 1 times 1 over
Sigma 1 is a 1 and the other next guy is
a 1 and the rest are all 0 that's right
it's the best I could do the rank was
only two so I couldn't get anywhere so
that tells you what Sigma plus is okay
so I described the pseudo-inverse then
with a picture of spaces and then with a
formula of matrices and now I want to
use it in least squares so now I'm going
to say what is the least squares problem
and the first way to solve it will be to
let do to involve a plus will give the
solution okay so what is the what is the
least squares problem let me put it here
[Applause]
okay the least squares problem is simply
you have an equation ax equal B but a is
not invertible so you can't solve it of
course for which yeah you could find you
could solve it for certain B's if B is
in the column space of a then just by
the meaning of column space this has a
solution the vectors in the column space
are the guys that you can get but the
vectors in the orthogonal space you
cannot get all the rest of the vectors
you cannot get so suppose this is like
so but always a is M by n rank R and
that that then we get a inverse when M
equals N equals R that's the invertible
case ok what do we do with a system of
equations when we can't solve it that's
this is probably the main application in
1806 so you've seen this problem before
what do we do if ax equal B has no
solution
so typically B would be a vector of
measurements like we're tracking a
satellite and we get some measurements
but and often we get too many
measurements and of course there's a
little noise in them and a little noise
means that we can't solve the equations
that maybe we're the case everybody
knows is where a where this this
equation is like expressing a straight
line going through the data point so the
the famous example of these squares is
fit a straight line a straight line to
the B's 2 B 1 B 2 we've got em
measurements we've got em measurements
the physics or the mechanics of the
problem is pretty well linear but of
course there's noise and the straight
line only has two degrees of freedom
however so we're going to have only two
columns in our matrix a will be only two
columns with many rows highly
rectangular so fit a straight line let
me call that line CX Plus D say this is
the X direction this is the the bees
direction and we've got a whole bunch of
data points and they're not on a line or
they are in a line what how would I how
what suppose those did lie on the line
what would that tell me about ax equal B
I haven't said everything I need to but
maybe the insight is what I'm after here
if I if my points are right on a line so
there is a straight line through them
the unknowns here is so low B so ax the
unknowns here are
C&D and the right hand side is all my
measurements okay suppose without my
drawing a picture
suppose the these points are on the line
here here's the different X's the
measurement x here's the different
measurements but if they're on a line
what does that tell me about my linear
system ax equal B it has a solution
being on a line means everything's
perfect there is a solution but will
there usually be a solution certainly
not if I have only two parameters two
unknowns two columns here the rank is
going to be two and here I'm trying to
hit any noisy set of measurements so of
course in general the picture will look
like that and I'm gonna look for the
best C and D so I'll call it C X C CX
Plus D yeah right sorry that's that's my
line so those are my equation so oh
sorry I often write it C plus D X do you
mind if I put the constant term first in
the in the highly difficult equation
here for a straight line so let me tell
you what I'm so these are the the points
where you have a measurement X 1 X 2 up
to X M and these are the actual
measurements B 1 up to BM let's say and
then my equations are yeah
I'm just want to set up your matrix here
I just want to set up the matrix so I
want C to get multiplied by ones every
time and I want deed
get multiplied by these X's X 1 X 2 X 3
X M the measurement places and there was
a measurements anyway and the part my
problem is this has no solution and so
so what do I do when there's no solution
well well I'll do what gauss did he was
a good mathematician so i'll follow his
advice and I won't do it all semester as
you know
so but Gauss's advice was minimize I'll
blame it on the Gauss the distance
between a x + B squared the l2 norm
squared which was which is just a X
minus B transpose ax minus B it's a
quadratic and minimizing it gives me a
system of linear equations so in the end
they will have a solution so that's the
whole point of these squares we have an
unsolvable problem not no solution we
follow a Gauss's advice to get the best
we can and that does produce an answer
so this is this is if I multiply this as
out as X transpose a transpose ax that
comes from the square term and then I
have probably these actually will
probably I'll get two of those and then
a constant term that has derivative 0 so
it doesn't enter so this is what I'm
minimizing this is the loss function and
it leads to let's just jump to the so
the to the key here what equation do I
get when I
for what equation is solved by the best
X the best X the best act solves the
famous so this is regression and
statistics linear regression
one of the main computations and
statistics not of course just for
straight line fits but for any system ax
equal B that will lead to this minimum
will lead to a system of equations that
I'm going to put a box around because
it's so fundamental and are you willing
to tell me what that equation is yes
thanks a transpose a it's gonna come
from there you see it times the best x
equals a transpose B that gives the
minimum
let me forego checking that you you see
that the quadratic term has the matrix
in it so it's derivative is may be may
be the derivative of this is to a
transpose ax and then the two cancels
that two and this could also be written
as X transpose a transpose B so it's X
transpose against a transpose B that's
linear so when I take the derivative
it's that country that's pretty fast
1806 would patiently derive that but
here I let me give you the picture that
goes with it the geometry so we have we
have the problem no solution we have
Gauss's
best answer minimize the to norm of the
error we have the conclusion the matrix
that we get in and now I want to draw a
picture that goes with it okay so here
is a picture I want to I want to have
column space of a there in that picture
of course the zero vectors in the column
space of a so this is this is all
possible vectors ax right
you're never forgetting that the column
space is all the a X's now I've got to
put B in the picture so where does this
vector B so I'm trying to solve ax equal
B but failing so what if I draw B in
this picture how do I draw B where do I
put it
shall I put it in the column space no
the whole point is it's not in the
column space it's not an ax it's out
there somewhere B okay and then what's
the geometry that goes with these
squares and the normal equations and
Gauss's suggestion to minimize the error
what will where will ax be the best ax
that I can do
where will so so so Gauss is what Gauss
has produced is a an a the other he
can't find an X he'll do his best he can
and we're calling that guy X hat and
this is the algebra to find X hat and
now where's the picture here where is
this vector ax hat which is the best ik
ax we can get so it has to be
in the column space because it's a times
something and where is it in the column
space
it's the projection that's a x half and
here's the error which you couldn't do
anything about B minus a X F yeah so
it's the projection right so that all
this is justifying the so we're we're in
the second approach to these squares
solves the normal equations solve the
normal equations yeah that would be the
second approach to least squares and
most examples if they're not very big or
very difficult you just creates a matrix
a transpose a and you call MATLAB and
solve that linear system you create the
matrix you create the right hand side
and you solve it so that's the ordinary
run-of-the-mill
these squares problems just do it so
that's method 2 just do it
what's method 3 for the same we're
talking about the same problem here but
now I'm thinking it may be a little more
difficult this matrix a transpose a
might be nearly singular Gauss is
assuming that yeah yeah when did this
work when did this work and it will
continue to work in the next three this
works this is good if assuming a has
independent columns
ya better just make clear I'm claiming
that when a hasn't so what's the what's
the reasoning if a has independent
columns but maybe not enough columns
like here it's only got two columns
that's obviously not going to be able to
match any right hand side but it's got
independent columns when a has
independent columns then what can I say
about this matrix it's invertible
Gauss's plan works if a has independent
columns then this would be a linear
algebra step then this will be
invertible you see the importance of
that step if a has independent columns
that means it has no null space only X
equal zero is in the null space two
independent columns but only two so not
enough to solve systems but independent
then you're okay this matrix is
invertible you can do what Gauss tells
you but we're prepared now we have to
think okay so that what do I really want
to do I want to connect this Gauss's
solution to the pseudo inverse because
I'm claiming they both give the same
result the pseudo inverse yeah the
pseudo inverse will apply but we have we
have like something this a is not
invertible just keep keep remembering
this matrix it's not invertible but it's
it has got independent columns what am i
saying they're just just going back to
the picture
if if a has is a matrix with independent
columns what space disappears in this
picture the null space goes away so the
picture is simpler but it's still the
null space of a of a transpose this is
still pretty big because I only had two
columns and a whole lot of rows and
that's gonna be reflected here
so what what am I trying to say I'm
trying to say that this answer is the
same as the pseudo-inverse answer do we
could possibly even check that point let
me write it down first
I claim that the answer a plus B is the
same as the answer coming from here a
transpose a inverse a transpose B when I
guess the null space is zero the rank is
all of em whatever you like to say I
believe that that that method one this
to it in one quick formula so remember
that this was V Sigma plus u transpose
right that's what a a transpose was that
this should agree with this I I believe
those are the same when the null space
isn't in the picture so the fact that
the null space is just a zero vector
means that this in this inverse does
exist so this inverse exists but but a a
transpose is not invertible
right no wait no inverse because a a
transpose would be coming with a
transpose all this is a null space of a
transpose so a transpose is not
invertible but but a transpose a is
invertible could you how would you check
that you see when i'm it's taken like
pretty much the whole hour to get a
picture of the geometry of the
pseudo-inverse so this is the pseudo
inverse and this is that matrix there
what you know it's really doing its best
to be the inverse in fact everybody here
is just like doing their best to be the
inverse now how well is this how close
is that to being the inverse can I just
ask you about that and then I'll make
this connection and then we're out of
time how close is that to being the
inverse of a suppose I multiply that by
a what do I get so so just notice if I
multiply that by a what do I get
I get yeah I get I terrific but don't be
deceived to thinking that this is the
inverse of a it only it worked on the
left side but it's not going to be good
on the right-hand side so if I try if I
multiply a by this guy in that direction
I'll get like as close to the identity
as I can come but I won't get the
identity that way so this is this a
little box to say
so what's the point of making I'm
claiming that this is the pseudo-inverse
whatever whatever these spaces the rain
could be tiny just just one this works
when the rank is in this I needed
independent columns so when the rank is
in so this is rank equal and that that
Gauss worked then I can get a one then
it's a one-sided inverse but it's not a
two-sided inverse I can't do that but my
matrix there I could find a one-sided
inverse to get the 2 by 2 identity but I
could never
multiply that by some matrix and get the
N by n identity those two pathetic
columns okay
maybe you feel like just checking this
just takes patience what do I mean by
checking it I mean stick in the pseudo
the the SVD just put in the SVD and
cancel like crazy and I think that'll
pop out do you like believe me cuz it's
gonna be a little painful 3 you know you
say my V transpose all transposed and
then something there and suddenly there
I've got 9 matrices multiplying away but
it's gonna like how all sorts of things
will produce the identity and in the end
that's what I'll have right right yep so
that's this is the this is the it's a
one-sided true inverse where the SVD
this formula is prepared to have neither
side invertible it's still we know what
Sigma plus means anyway so under the
assumption of independent columns Gauss
works and gives the same answer as their
pseudo inverse
okay three minutes
that's hardly time but this being a
mighty I feel I should use it oh my god
number three so what's number three
about number three is is a is a as the
same requirement as number two the same
requirement of no null space but it says
if I could get orthogonal columns first
then this problem would be easy so
everybody knows that gram-schmidt is a
way boring way to get from from from
these two columns to get two orthogonal
columns actually the whole idea of
gram-schmidt is already there for
two-by-two so with so I have two minutes
and we can do it let's see let's do
gram-schmidt on these two columns column
column a column column you accountant I
don't want to use U and V column y&z
okay suppose I want to orthogonalize
those guys what's the gram-schmidt idea
i take why it's perfectly good no
problem with y there's the y vector
they're all ones then this guy is not
orthogonal probably to that it'll go off
and some this in this direction with an
angle that's not ninety degrees so what
do i do i want to get orthogonal vectors
I'm okay with this first guy but the
second guy isn't orthogonal to the first
so what do I do
how do I in this picture how do I come
up with a vector orthogonal to Y project
I could I take this Z and I take its
projection so Z has a little piece
that Z vector has a little big piece
already in the direction of what Y which
I don't want and a piece orthogonal to
it that's my other piece that's my other
piece so here's why and here's the the
this is that is Z minus the minus a
projection let me just say whatever yeah
I don't know if I even drew that picture
right probably I didn't anyway whatever
the the gram-schmidt idea is just
orthogonalize in the natural way oh I'll
come back to that at the beginning of
next time and say a word about the
fourth way but but so this least squares
is is not deep learning it's what people
did a century ago and continue to do for
good reason okay and I'll send out that
announcement about the class and you
know the homework and you know the new
due date is Friday good thank you